this morning a partnership bringing two
worlds together one part is the ghetto
Film School GFS started more than 20
years ago it was a program that gave
kids from a predominantly minority
community in New York the power to tell
their stories now GFS has a global
presence with offices in Los Angeles and
London and for the last two years has
teamed up with another group with a
history of being mistreated the Jewish
community
we met a few of them in the South Bronx
first word that comes to mind when you
think GFS
opportunity new community caring
collaboration I would say storytelling
it's not every day you find a group of
students from the Bronx working
alongside kids from a Manhattan Jewish
Day School the timeline is where we
build out our projects but a
two-year-old partnership between the
ghetto film school and the Ramada School
aims to curb racism and anti-Semitism
with an Arts Alliance projects from kids
like Lila ellman and David Rubin so
you're working on a story where the two
main suspects in a murderer one is a
black man and the other Jewish man yeah
it is loaded yes I'm sorry I didn't what
we did was uh we invited our history
teacher a black woman and we had them
cook two different dishes together one
black and one Jewish inspired by their
cultures and then we had them mix them
together to sort of create the Synergy
between the two
we should be the ones to tell our
stories the ghetto Film School a two and
a half year free program funded by
wealthy donors and championed by
celebrities was formed back in 2000 by
Joe Hall the ghetto Film School the name
I mean I think it clearly is is ironic
up front and but over the years it's you
know the reputation the quality of the
programs and certainly what the students
have gone on to to do in their own lives
it's all part of the name we put it in
the name for a reason
to redefine the stories about us written
by people who aren't Us hall had some
pretty clear ideas about how he wanted
to do things differently when it came to
non-profits and education we never call
them at risk disadvantaged none of the
stuff that most people use particularly
when you're talking about young people
of color no labels for the kids
no and this is sometimes funders have a
hard thing with this because you know
they have boxes to check off and we say
well we don't really keep that
information our curriculum is based on
graduate level Film School in 2021
montaya Robinson became CEO of GFS the
work the assignments the classroom
instruction is industry standard the
content what they're looking to make is
Guided by that and there's a real
emphasis on critical discussion both
peer-to-peer and then from student to
instructor
action
all students who work with GFS are
immersed in every facet of cinematic
storytelling and production
the program culminates with a short
thesis project filmed in a different
foreign location every year with real
actors and professional level equipment
for our thesis project we travel to the
Dominican Republic and we make a short
film about essentially about the culture
and inspired by the Dominican culture
I'm curious about you know how can we
improve the pacing of the film now Kayla
Mora just completed the final step
before shooting a table read complete
with experienced writers directors
actors and Business Leaders who offer
invaluable feedback just seeing objects
does so much and I think you don't want
to hold Donny's hand Jared Ray went to
Shanghai for his thesis in 2011 and now
works in the film industry that was an
amazing experience definitely one that
you know opened my world being from the
Bronx being forced to write a story
where I'm not from and trying to adapt
to that kind of Storytelling it was
definitely challenging but it was super
humbling and rewarding to be able to
tell that kind of story
held sick is the GFS board member who
first came up with the idea to partner
with ramaz as much as we focus on the
education of our kids it's incomplete if
we're not getting them out of their
comfort zone and their bubble for them
to appreciate that this country is about
us it's not just about the Jewish
Community it's about all the other folks
who live around us
for those of you in ramaz or graduates
how much time had you spent in the South
Bronx before this
I don't I really don't I feel like not
so much Queen's kid
yeah I don't think at all I went to the
Bronx Zoo a few times but that's it
same here probably went to the Bronx
when I was younger but yeah everybody's
talked about community and that's one
thing that sort of has resonated for me
you're a student but then like you you
stay involved in the program so many
people do for for decades
right yeah and being able to teach these
wonderful students here from ramaz has
been
um really amazing because you're able to
sort of there's a level of give back but
there's also a level of learning from
your students as well Keisha Ramel both
an instructor at ramaz and a GFS
graduate knows one of the best weapons
against ignorance is opportunity
opportunities wasn't big enough for all
of us really the whole point of ghetto
film school so we made a new one from
the start I don't buy into this coddling
culture thing of like you know everyone
has to be sort of treated with kit
gloves and the success of ghetto film
school has always been high expectations
rigor uh not everyone's a winner but
you're here to do your thing and be your
creative self and uh you're given the
opportunity to do that and the resources
but in the end it's it's going to be
your commitment of where you take that
they really Pride themselves in that
critical discussion and that is if
you're looking at a film that stinks
they say it stinks right and you can
maybe take another shot at it but as
they say they give people the
opportunity what you do with that
opportunity is what you do with it
that's but that's half the battle
because if you're not given that
opportunity you don't know what you can
do and it's a huge opportunity bringing
students from different neighborhoods
together and then going abroad and
learning about that culture I mean
that's the best education the advice